To to
to to Radiolab from NPR and W, N, Y,
c ladies and gentlemen, the president of the United States.
[inaudible]
June 26 2010 19:00 AM the White House.
This is the moment race died.
Good morning.
We're here to celebrate the completion of the first survey of the entire human
genome or the entire human genome of the entire see for a hundred years
scientists or at least a certain group of scientists had been trying to prove
that race is weird. It's not just something that we see with our eyes,
but in fact there is something fundamentally different between a person who is
white and a person who is black or Asian and they looked at blood differences,
nothing. They looked at differences in musculature, the size of our heads,
nothing. They couldn't really say, this is this and that is that.
Then the entire human genome in 2000 it is my great pleasure.
Bill Clinton introduces two of the most important scientists in the world.
Dr. Francis Collins and Craig venter. Both of them get up to the podium and say,
look, we have searched all the way down to our DNA.
Can't get any deeper than that and when it comes to race,
the concept of race as no genetic or scientific basis,
it's just not there.
What that means is that modern science is confirmed what we first learned from
ancient sites.
The most important fact of life on this earth is our common humanity.
[inaudible]
a couple of years down the road, if you fast forward,
we began to look more closely and we began to notice some subtle differences
based on ethnic background differences,
differences in people's health and raped and the differences seemed like they
could be important that some genetic diseases target racial or ethnic groups
more than others so that now, just a couple of years later,
even some of the scientists who were on the podium that day saying it was all
over even they have started to rethink. Are we rolling?
Yes, we're rolling. We are rolling. All right. That's Francis Collins,
head of the human genome project.
And then in 2000 you were standing with Bill Clinton and um, and Craig Venter,
you remember this day? I do remember June 26 2000 yes.
I'm pretty hard to forget that one. What was the weather like out of curiosity?
That was really hot that morning,
but really we didn't want to talk to Francis about that day.
We actually wanted to ask him about something he said couple of years
afterwards, something he wrote in a medical journal. Jack,
could you read the not defensive saying not this. Oh,
well I'll just read it to you. This is you talking. Okay, here it,
this increasing scientific evidence, however,
indicates that genetic variation can be used to make a reasonably accurate
prediction of geographic origins.
It is not strictly true that race or ethnicity has no biological connection.
So that's what we're kind of wandering it.
That it's not strictly true that it has no biological connection.
Is it here fully live though?
I won't defend that as being the world's best sentence construction.
But there's something that you want to say that you don't quite pass through
your lips, it sounds like, but, well, let me try again here.
I think there are two points you can make about race and genetics.
One is we're really all very much alike, incredibly alike,
but you can also say even that small amount of difference turns out to be
revealing.
[inaudible].
So that's our show today. What exactly can science reveal about race?
Does it exist? Does it not exist? What really can you say about it?
Yes, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab.
[inaudible]
okay, ready? Three, two, one.
So let's go back and consider Francis Collins is state.
It is not strictly stop. Stop.
So it's not strictly speaking true that race has no biological connection.
Who are you? I'm Nell Greenfield boys.
I'm a science reporter with National Public Radio. But for the moment I'm your,
I'm your grammar instructor.
So take this double negative and make it into a sentence that is without the
double negative. [inaudible] says no, it is sort of,
it's sort of true that race has something to do with biology. Right, right,
right, right. But while he is tiptoeing around with his fancy double negatives,
some people out in the real world sounds like a cell phone.
I'm getting rid of that right now.
Are taking that concept and they're just running with it. Hello.
Can you hear me? Hello? Hello. Who's, who's running with it? Exactly.
And how good, well I talked with one detective in Louisiana. I,
let me just make sure I have your name pronounced correctly.
My name is Kip Judy's.
I am the a patrol commander at the Lafayette Parish Sheriff's Office at the rank
of captain who says that he actually used DNA to say something about race.
When was this all going down? I'm see 2002, 2003 and that,
that helped him catch a serial killer. Um,
w we had a victim who had been bludgeoned. Yes.
Ronisha column was only 23 years old.
She was left in a field and found by some hunters.
It is believed her final moments alive were spent visiting her mother's grave,
her abandoned car, discovered her vehicle, was found,
abandoned the cemetery right near her mother's grave site. And just over a year,
four women have been murdered in Louisiana. Their deaths linked by DNA evidence,
no evidence at all of the crime scenes that point through a single killer serial
killer. The media dubbed him the Baton Rouge serial killer.
He was in the news almost daily self defense classes are filling with frightened
women. Where will he strike next? Based on some witness information,
this suspected is believed
to be a white male. He is described as a white male, white male
in a white truck. Everything at that point they had made,
it seemed like it was probably a white guy. Yes.
I mean they had this eyewitness report.
The fact that there seemed to be a serial killer and most serial killers are
thought to be white guys and they started testing hundreds of white men.
Police have launched an extraordinary effort to take DNA samples,
DNA samples from nearly a thousand men.
They were doing kind of a genetic dragnet dragnet for a serial killer in an area
where crime tape is becoming part of the landscape. Bob McNamara,
CBS News, Baton Rouge did. It
wasn't looking very, very promising. So they went and they asked,
you know, their crime lab,
is there anything in a DNA profile that identifies race?
And then we have the perpetrator's DNA.
Can we look at that and say whether it's a white guy or a black guy?
The immediate answer we had was no, it's not. You can't do that. Not a,
there's not a marker.
There's not a gene because you know race is not biological. Right. However,
there was some technology out there that was looking into it.
We're the first company I,
I think in the world is in for phenotypes for forensics cases. Oh,
that's Tony for daycares. He owns a company in Florida that sells tests,
genetic tests that he claims can be like an eye witness and tell you something
about a person, what they look like.
Characteristics like eye colors and hair colors and skin color.
And the cops in Louisiana took him up on it.
We submitted the suspect profile to them and when the test came back,
this particular case, the individual is primarily of
African ancestry. A black guy? Yes.
Over 90% likely that it was a black male.
I do think it's important to note that there were other lines of evidence that
had been developing that made them think a black eye was likely,
but the DNA result,
I mean that was science within three or four days after that state police called
and said, we have a match.
The rest is history. He's since been convicted of two of the murders to wait.
They caught the guy and he was in fact black. Yes.
So does that mean that Tony for
free debt free, what is it for daycares?
Tony for Degas has somehow found the gene for race
that there is a race gene.
It's much more complicated than that and,
and it all boils down to this idea of ancestry
ancestry by dna.com you can go online and his company DNA print and again and
they will send you a kit with just a simple mal swab you do at home.
You can discover your unique genetic ancestry. Okay.
My kid and it's like a little science
kit. Yeah. We're listening to Chad.
I taking a DNA test while being interrupted by his wife taking a DNA test and
it's got these like swabs in one of these sterols swabs and you like,
you know, rub your cheek with it.
Ah Huh.
You literally just send this through the mail to the DNA print corporate
headquarters in Sarasota, Florida and I went there.
Hi. Good. I'm now greenfield voice. Okay,
so after the cheek cells arrive in Florida,
and this is where items of evidence come [inaudible] state run it through a
bunch of machines.
What exactly in the end are they looking at that gives them like some sense of
my race. Well, in your DNA there's lots of information.
There's billions of different little DNA letters, letters, letters,
letters, letters, letters, letters, letters.
Can we play with this just for a second?
If I were to have you recite all the letters in your DNA, one letter per second,
know how long it would take you to spell yourself our, no, no.
It would take you six months. A century,
[inaudible] century to make it even more interesting instead of just you.
Let's have you compared to me. I mean like if we both read it at one per second,
yeah.
We would be absolutely identical for about 17 minutes before there'd be any
difference between us. Wow. And every difference that there is,
or whether it's like a little chemical tea or a little chemical g or,
or whatever has a story behind it. How do you mean? Well,
we all started in the same place together. Well,
the evidence is very good that the human race, as we currently know,
it had its origins in Africa according to Francis Collins,
head of the human genome project in the neighborhood of a hundred thousand years
ago with as few as 10,000 people. But soon after that,
humans began to fan out across the world. Some of us went east into Arabia.
Some of us went up north across the Sahara into the Mediterranean area.
All the while, all these people are having baby
and in the process, the DNA is getting copied over and over and over,
parent to parent the kid. But sometimes the copying isn't exactly perfect.
So every so often you'll find it company error.
Whoo. Hey, hey, no, yes. That one right there.
Let's imagine that error. Hey, no,
occurred in Asia about 25,000 years ago. Imagine a Chinese woman,
Pat ABB, and the baby was one letter different from the mommy.
I'm accident the a and the mom became ah,
in the baby and then that c was handed down.
Well, you like to see any other seat.
And a thousand years down the road I look into your DNA.
I see that same mistake in the same spot. You know what?
I know what I now have a hunch and if I show to a family tree really hard,
some Chinese ancestors would pop out.
It's sort of like a souvenir that your ancestors handed you down in your blood
that you carry with you in every cell in your body.
So they've identified about 180 little variations in the DNA,
little souvenirs that people who share ancestry, um,
share. This is the way to put it. We sample. Did you send him? Was It yours?
Oh, I'm not going to tell you. Yeah, that's all right. You tell me. Yeah,
we'll show you. We've got it on a CD. So we leave the,
and we go down this hallway to his office, determine that it is of alien origin.
That would explain a lot actually.
He pulls these things up on his computer screen.
I'll show you what your results were. So what does it say? I'm dying here. Well,
I guess before I tell you, okay, that sample was determined to be,
I want to know what you, what you think, what do you think it's going to be?
Um, well my folks are Arab light-skin both of them.
My Dad's got some darker skin people on his side of the family.
So if I had to guess, probably some European in there. And then my dad's side,
I was thinking, well,
they're probably like Greek or Turkish way back when I don't,
I wasn't really sure and I consciously didn't sort of look into it. Okay.
Well let me just tell you that this test you took is not going to tell you
countries. Right, right. Okay. I'm oddly kind of nervous weirdly.
Really? Yeah. Just a little bit. So a,
your sub Saharan African ancestry, what percentage are you thinking?
I'm going to guess 12 0% zero 0% huh?
All right. Native American ancestry,
1% one east Asian, 5% wow.
European,
94% really 94% 94%
European. Oh 94% pounds.
They note that the words that we're using here are pretty arbitrary.
You should understand that his definition of quote unquote European includes the
fertile crescent or the Middle East. Wow. So, so wait a second.
If I'm a police member,
we started this conversation and a cop was looking to describe a perpetrator,
right? So if I find out that Jen at boom rod is European,
then I'm looking for someone who could be a huge range.
We're looking at the computer screen now and for example,
you've pulled up a bunch of digital photos when Tony foodic has pulled up
pictures of people with my exact ancestral mix from the database,
a database. Here's um, some males,
here's a female, he brought up people with blonde hair, blue eyes.
These are all people that had this sort of mix.
Even people from Poland who had like really red cheeks.
So the these folks just look like pretty much like white folks to me.
Run of the mill. Cause I got to tell,
let me show you the picture of the guy who actually gave the sample
that Mr [inaudible] does not know that Chad is a dark curly hair swarthy man.
So this is the guy and he doesn't really know anything about his ancestry but
his mother and father I believe are from Lebanon.
Although in this sample of maybe 20 people,
it's just that we don't have any samples of Lebanese and [inaudible] for a cop.
Someone who describes themselves as Lebanese versus Polish.
I mean that would be a really big difference. Oh yeah. And and to,
to make that sort of a distinction, you need different markers set. Well,
so then what, what does DNA actually tell you then? Well, not a lot.
That's direct.
What he's doing basically is playing a guessing game based on ancestral
percentages. Like for instance, I'm 90% European, 0% subsaharan.
He can plug that in to his database,
pull up the pictures and he will notice that nobody with those percentages is
black. So he can tell. He'll tell police this guy, probably not black.
Just like at the beginning we just had that.
That perpetrator there was pretty much not why. Yeah.
Now there is one thing he can read directly in our DNA.
What eye color? Hmm. So at the end of the day he can say,
I am not black and I have brown eyes. That's it. That's as far as he can go.
That's all he can tell you is a scientist. He does take it further. Oh,
what did he do? Well, if he's got a DNA sample of a perp,
he can go to his computer database. You can say, okay, database,
show me everybody who's got these exact same percentages.
Show me their pictures.
Now tell me what all of these faces have in common visually,
like what's their average nose wet, what's their average shape of the ears?
How big are their skulls? Skull Shave.
You see where this is going and then what he tells the police look for.
It's for people who have, you know, this type of head kind of ear.
This isn't genetics. Now, this is just photo average photo averaging.
This is in sciences or something else. Great.
But when you hear things like measuring skulls, measuring ears,
it's hard not to think back to pretty nasty periods of our history.
Like the Eugenesis, they tried to composite pictures into one face,
they measured skulls and they ended up inspiring the number
if people called you a racist, not once,
not once have I been called a racist.
Not once.
That kind of surprises me. I'm just sort of wondering how,
how do you think you've escaped that?
Hmm?
Are People critical of this? Uh, yeah.
I think a lot of scientists are first knee jerk reaction is,
is that the poor masses out there aren't intelligent enough to handle this sort
of information.
They all start climbing over one another and killing themselves so that we
either, you know,
the smart ones need to sort of obfuscate and I don't think that works very well.
People may be a lot smarter than we might give them credit for being,
I think he's onto something there. What do you mean? Well,
there is a tendency that people have when this subject comes up to say we don't
talk about that.
Maybe I think people can talk about the real world and real differences
respectfully and even with a certain amount of delicious interest. Sure.
Yeah. Well you say sure, but there are lots of shutters everywhere.
You're not going to get me to stand on the side of shushing. It's just, I mean,
science complicates things. Even now, this whole, you know,
definition that science has of race being like ancestry or whatever, it just,
it, it just doesn't jive with how people live. Race.
You mean how people talk about it? Really? Yeah. Look it. Look here.
Take a look at this photo. This one here? Yup. Yeah. You see the guy there? Yes.
What race do you think he is? He's back. Definitely black, definitely. Oh yeah.
How black is he? How black is he? What kind of a question? Just for a visual.
Black. Black. How about Obama? Black? No, he's not. He's blacker than that.
So he's unequivocally black, right? I don't know. My parents
taught us because they came from the segregated south.
You were either black or you are white. There was no in between.
So the guy you're looking at, the guy we just heard, that's a Wayne Joseph.
He's in an education director in La and he also on the side writes essays about
race, mostly for national magazines. And one day, a couple of years back,
he was watching TV
and I happened to see a TV program highlighting the fact that a couple of DNA
labs were actually doing racial testing on DNA. Light Bulb went on.
I said, well, this will be perfect for this essay.
He thought he tests himself,
see what percentage of him was black versus other stuff and then write about it,
but what, what number did you think you would be?
The number I was thinking was 70 or 75% or more.
75% African and 25% who knows what, sorry.
I sent away for the kids, swap both cheeks, put it in a vial, sent it back,
and then
a few weeks later I get back the results.
First thing I did was I checked the kit number to make sure that they hadn't
made a mistake and sent me someone else's results. But the kit number matched,
I couldn't believe it.
57% Indo-European 39% native American,
4% Asian and 0% African,
0% as in as in zero. Nothing.
I mean I've,
I've lived 50 years as a black man and I have no African genetically
[inaudible].
How did you make sense of that? Did you, did it sick and all at once?
Um, no. What happened was after a couple of days,
I hadn't told my wife anything yet. I went to see my mother and I said, look,
there's only one really logical explanation I can live with.
It's okay. I love you. Just tell me the truth.
I'm adopted. She kind of giggled and she said, look,
I can remember every pain I had having you. I can still remember it.
I said, well, but then this doesn't make any sense.
She said, yeah, it's a little surprising but I'm too old,
too tired to be anything else.
So that's just the way it is for my brother.
When I told him the results, he said, why not your DNA?
That's not my DNA. I'm a black man and that's the end of it for him. Hmm.
What about your wife? Well, my second wife happens to be Jewish.
Her response was, what do you mean you're a black man?
I defied my mother to marry you. You've got to be black. Whoa.
So she needed you to be black? Absolutely,
because she had told her mother at the time, look, I'm marrying Wayne.
You're going to have to decide whether you're going to him or looser daughter.
[inaudible]
it really threw me for a loop. You start thinking about your life.
There are certain decisions that are made in life based on who you think you
are. Would I have married a black woman the first time?
Would I have decided to go to a black high school?
Do you have answers to those questions? Would you have married a black woman?
Would you have gone to a black high school? Maybe not.
How different would my life have been if I'd have known this 45 years ago?
[inaudible]
Wayne Joseph is the director of alternative education for the Chino Valley
School district in California.
A radio lab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation and the
corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Apple. I'm Rod and I'm Robert Krulwich.
Today's program is about race. Okay, so where are we literally learn?
We've learned that scientists, when they talk about race,
they don't really mean race. No,
they mean that you have a set of ancestors who lived in a particular place on
this planet for a while. While they were there, they acquired certain features,
skin color, hair texture, whatever,
and scientists won't go much further than just that. But here's the thing,
if you forget the lab scientist for a second,
if you're a doctor and your job is to save lives,
you can't help but notice that there are real differences between groups in
terms of how healthy people are. And if you want to treat that,
you end up talking about race and it never goes well. Let me tell you,
the story now comes from our producer, Soren Wheeler,
and it's about a drug called Bidell. So you popped a few vital this morning.
I did. I just wanted to test it out.
That you're supposed to is it loosens up the arteries that's supposedly so it's
easier for the heart to pump as a white man that's about to talk about race on
the radio. I figured it's time to loosen up. Okay.
To introduce me to, to, to our main dude here. I'm Dr Jay cone,
a professor of medicine at the University of Minnesota Medical School.
This is him. And what did you have for breakfast this morning?
I don't eat breakfast. Tell me what it looks like. Well, he's a stocky,
he's got a white beard.
He's Kinda got that wearied grave doctor look probably because he spent his
entire career worrying about how to help people with heart failure.
That's right. Which for a really long time was kind of a lost cause. Oh yeah.
It was a hopeless disease and that once it developed, uh, uh,
the implication was that the patient would die. You're done.
There was nothing much we could do, but keep the patient comfortable.
But then back in the early seventies, [inaudible] had kind of a breakthrough.
The aha moment was the first patient bedridden.
Patient can breathe easily bubbling up with fluid in the lungs.
Jake gave this patient a combination of two and the moment we did that,
this patients suddenly said, Mike, come on,
I can breathe easily for the first time in months that fast. Oh,
it's dream. It's immediate.
You confirms the effect. In a longer term trial over five years,
he gets a patent, he finds a company,
they put it in a pill and they take it to the FDA. And that's when the FDA said,
no, no, no, that's what they said. Why? No,
you just said it worked really well. Well, the doctor's on the review board,
they said they thought the drug was pretty good. Yeah,
they even started using it with some of their patients,
but they denied approval because it was not a big study study was just too
small. In the entire trial. There were only 86 people that got the drug.
We were disappointed, frustrated, and we were using it.
I was using it in my patients brag. Yeah,
so he goes back to what he was doing before all this started,
which was trying to figure out what the hell is going on with heart failure?
What the hell? What's going on with heart failure at that point? Well,
at the time scientists were just starting to look at racial differences when it
comes to things like high blood pressure and heart problems that that black
Americans were suffering a lot more than white Americans as he,
so he must've been hearing all this stuff.
This debate was going on out there and Jay was listening,
so Jay started thinking, you know,
he had all that old data and they had actually broken it up by race.
Everyone checked a box, black, white, American, Indian, all that.
They'd never bothered to look at that stuff. Never teased it out. And I said,
we should go back into our database. Just maybe,
maybe black people respond differently to Bidell. Well,
we thought it would be worthwhile to go back and look.
We didn't know what we were going to find.
We just went back and checked off those people who had said they were black.
Jesus, we
gathered up the data and when they looked at the numbers, oh my God,
he saw a bump. What do you mean? Well, still just a small trial.
But in that trial, the black patients did better, significantly better. Really.
So we published and a couple of weeks later,
he gets a call from a drug company and they say,
we'd like to do something with Bidell.
They would be willing to do a trial to demonstrate the efficacy of Baidu.
But here's the thing,
they wanted to do the trial just with black people that seem to be the path of
least resistance. Why would they,
why would they want to eliminate just a black people? Well,
they could do a smaller study, so it would be cheaper.
And when it came time to sell the drug, ready-made market. All right,
so they do this big study only in black people and black people.
And what do they find? An amazing result?
We get a 43% reduction in mortality by what? In other words,
if you were a black person in this trial and you took vital,
your chance of dying from heart failure was cutting half. Whoa, roughly.
That's huge. Huge. Yeah. So they go back and in 2005 that's Troy duster,
a sociologist at NYU,
the FDA approves this as a first racialized drug.
Think about that. The first racialized drug,
the first drug ever approved for racialized subpopulation
[inaudible]
after hundreds of years of looking for differences between black people and
white people after the mapping of the human genome, here's the FDA saying
[inaudible]
we're different. So some of us said this is a huge mistake.
We knew this was a terribly sensitive issues.
Move into the 21st century.
Well aware of the terrible history of racial and ethnic categories.
What should we do? Yeah.
We had a symposium to welcome you all program here at the University of
Minnesota.
We actually have a sold out crowd today than it was mainly aimed at attacking
[inaudible].
I just don't think race is a scientific category that there was a very well
known law professor,
so patients so hostile to the idea that she said I would rather die from heart
failure then take by doing, well that's not quite what she said.
I'd be terrified about a doctor making a diagnosis like that based on their view
of me as belonging to a particular racial category.
But it goes on all the [inaudible] that doesn't make it right.
That's why I say that does that right? It does.
If of these categories have, you know,
[inaudible] look [inaudible] Jack then to a doctor seeing an African American
with anemia. I said if you went into the doctor's office and were anemic,
the doctor would appropriately check you for sickle cell.
Just a natural everyday phenomenon. Right. And she insisted, well that's wrong.
I, I, you know,
there's cause sickle cell disease is not confined to black and misdiagnosed well
as she is right, of course.
But the statistical likelihood of a white person with sickle cell disease is so
low damaging their prevalence issues. There is a higher,
we can look at a patient and help identify some, uh,
processes of diagnosis and treatment that might improve our precision to
disregard that we need a better way to do it. But that's year 2005.
But you know what? I think that if we,
if seems to me that these racial categories are impeding good medical care and
good biomedical research, they're not assisting it.
Well I don't get that at all.
Why would the clearing a difference impede it seems exactly the opposite.
If you know that a group of people are likely to get sick in a certain way,
then you should target them and help them do them. Do you know what you think?
You know, I think is what she's saying. And by looking at one target group,
are you somehow shutting yourself off from the real target group that you should
be looking? I don't know what you're talking. Okay.
Let me give you know that black, let me give you an example. Okay.
When you go to the doctor, yes.
And they put that thing around your bicep and they go, yes,
the squeeze blood pressure. Okay.
It's well known in the black Americans have much higher rates of high blood
pressure. Hypertension. Yes. It is. Then generic,
which is my point that so know that hold up help.
It can seem like it's caused by race or it's purely a racial phenomenon,
but then I mentioned this to Troy duster. I said, how do you explain this?
Black Americans suffer like twice the amount of hypertension than white
Americans.
Make the argument from me that this is somehow not an innate difference. Okay.
The best argument here is Richard Cooper's. Yeah,
I'm Richard Cooper,
I'm sure the Department of Preventive Medicine and epidemiology here at Loyola,
which Cooper is a doctor and a researcher, and here's what he did.
He went to poor neighborhoods in Chicago and methodically taking blood samples,
measured people's blood pressure,
and then you took that data and compared it to other countries. Spain,
Italy, United Kingdom is huge. Germany,
eight nations sampling 85,000 people, 80,000 people,
85,000 and he then arrays nations in terms of hypertension
because he wants to know like who's got the highest rates? Who's got the lowest,
and does this really have anything to do with race, right?
Mm mm, mm, mm.
And at the very end, the nation with the highest rate of hypertension.
No tremor. Oh please.
[inaudible]
it's Germany, Germany, Germany. Actually Richard Cooper says that Finland,
Poland, and Russia are even worse. Right. Okay.
How many black people are in Russia? Seven.
Probably seven in the nation with the lowest rate of hypertension known as
Nigeria. No kidding. Yeah. And it's like this, it's not like this.
It's like you're putting your hands away. Yeah. Are for each other. Okay.
Your point being here, what exactly
not obvious. I mean,
if you're a doctor and you're just focused on the United States data,
you would assume that it has something to do with race.
He's high blood pressure disparities. So good. Therefore a miss.
All the Russians and fins that came into your office. B,
you would over-treat the American blacks and see,
God forbid a Nigerian should walk in because you're gonna give him all these
drugs he doesn't even need. Well then what does cause the differences?
Like if it's not race, what is it? If not race, what? Diet?
Yeah, Diet will really, Courtney, Richard Cooper. I know it's not that exciting,
but that's what he says. Well then what about bind all that.
You think that's wrong too? No, I mean,
but if you are the first drug ever to be approved for black people,
when you want to know that your drug works better for black people,
that's compared to other groups. Yes, and you want to be sure, right? Yes. Well,
they only ever tested it in black people.
They never actually compared blacks to whites. Yeah, well that's true.
We don't know and we haven't gone back and studied a large white population.
I personally believe that by deal will work in white people as well.
Maybe not to the same frequency, but I use it in my white patients.
Are you at all then upset that it's that certain wheeler, again,
it's FDA approved only for blacks. It's not getting to blacks.
I mean that's the real, what's he talking
about? Well, in the end, vital kind of tanked by, you know,
the way they priced and marketed the drug, all that kind of stuff.
But according to the Jay was also because of opposition to the idea
concept of vital that this is a drug for blacks,
it's a crime and that this life saving drug is not being as widely used as it
should be.
[inaudible]
I'm very discouraged about that.
so the takeaway here I guess is if a doctor or a scientist or a pharmaceutical
company announces that there is a racial difference in the human family,
check the footnotes. Exactly. On the other hand,
I think an awful lot of us in our regular life get all excited about racial
differences. When we watch sports, I mean ha everyone notices for example,
in track and field. Like why you all did you make in swim? Yeah, yeah.
In the hallways. Jamaican. So we found the Jamaican, I Roland Jamaican,
Malcolm Gladwell, a writer, Sota Jamaica.
He's Canadian Jamaican English,
also the author of the tipping point and I don't know all those bestselling
books we talked to him about his uh, his early days as a runner.
Am I running weight when I was 13 and 14 was about 105 hundred.
So you like just kind of danced on the grind?
I am 30 pounds heavier than I was in my running prime. Are you good? Uh,
you can be at that age. Yeah. Am I good in the global sense? No. Yeah.
Was I good at 13? I was really good. I was, I was all Canadian. Yeah.
Oh you are, you're number one in your country. And what event 1500 meters
and your age, class,
track and field in Ontario in the 1970s was so overwhelmingly west Indian.
It was in retrospect, it's hilarious. Think back on it.
I mean you would go to these track meets and there's like reggae music playing
in the end cause the entire time and the stands are full of Jamaicans.
So you are dealing with this fact, you know,
you're 13 you're not very sophisticated. You're dealing with this fact that
there just aren't any white people. It's all Jamaicans in lanes,
one through eight are all Jamaicans right off the boat Tobago.
And so you, you begin. And when you see it was really funny.
I remember there was a guy named Arnold Stotts and novels,
dots dominated the quarter mile for years in age class running.
Oh I don't start. Where's the white guy?
He was a white guy and we all looked at Arnold and we said,
it's not going to last, right? Can't last. Sure not it didn't.
You thought Arnold won't make it because he doesn't have the right stuff,
the right stuff being whatever it is that you make to make it.
The question was how long can Arnold keep beating the Jamaicans?
And the answer is it can't be for that much longer.
And he was a tremendous spinner,
but we had this kind of unspoken prejudice that said, if you weren't Jamaican,
it was hopeless. [inaudible] and did you ever have an opportunity at your,
at the age of 14 to ascribe this to anything? I'm mean,
I began to kind of process it in a very, very crude,
unsophisticated way.
And then I would look at the world and I would see in the world,
black people went all sprints. So I figured, well,
maybe just black people are faster than white people
in a very primitive young guy kind of way. Malcolm was,
I don't know exactly what the blade word for this is, but he was a racist,
chauvinist maybe. Or just somebody who sees west Indians winning everythings.
We figured there's gotta be a genetic advantage here because he could feel it in
himself. Listen, I had that gift. I was really,
really good when I was 15 and 14 and 30. I was the best in Canada.
I used to beat Dave Reed. Dave Reed went on. You beat Dave Reed, Dave,
even under the, and the Canadian Olympic team. Oh really? That was the thing.
That was the caliber of runner. I was,
will you and Dave Reed at the time when you were beating him? Uh, four, 14,
okay, let's make that clear. But now that he's older and slower and so, uh,
he's revised his thinking in this area.
I know longer and all that enamored of a kind of a genetic case for black
athletic superiority. I think it maybe explained some tiny amount,
but it's not the real issue.
Nature takes care of the fundamental things in the beginning. And then as we,
as activities grow more involved in more complex individual choice starts to
matter more and more and more and more. And when he says individual choice,
he's thinking of the moment when you're an athlete and it's the last turn or
maybe the last lap of a race.
When you've run 1200 meters in a 1500 meter race, oh,
you run six miles of a seven mile cross country race,
you're beginning to suffer. Pain is about to start.
You're in a position where you possibly can win if you exert yourself.
And that's the moment as Malcolm went, every athlete has to ask,
how much do I care?
There's always a struggle. Do I really care though?
Does it matter to me or do you think that Mickey Mantle or or, Oh,
I think everyone has it. You think all athletes have that question?
Some people say I do care and some people say I don't.
And how you answered that question,
yes or no has very little to do with jeans says mouth.
That's not the critical difference between me and tiger woods. You know,
it's the,
it's the tiger gets up at five in the morning and hits 10,000 golf balls before
breakfast. That's the difference.
Why does he want to do that and why is that inconceivable for me to do?
There's your interesting story. In Malcolm's case, he says he did love running.
You know when you're that age you really can't run forever.
I'll never forget the feeling,
but he also loved reading books and he loved going to school and he loved
thinking, it ain't like bring Bronx, I don't know.
My father comes from that glorious tradition of English amateurism which says
you should do many things and none of them. Well,
which in that critical moment made answering. Yes,
I will put up with the pain and win this race a little bit more difficult.
I struggled with it and I,
there was a moment when I had that conversation and I decided I didn't care.
And the moment happened when he was preparing for the Canadian national
championship, Canadian Championship, two of his friends who were also black.
I go for a run with this guy, Dave Reed, who's a great runner. [inaudible] yeah.
And another guy named Chris Brewster, another great runner of my generation.
At the time we would've thought of ourselves as equals,
but those guys didn't have as many options as Malcolm is a famous hill,
um, called Telegraph Hill. I know signal hill steep is the steepest.
It's like running up the steepest flight of steps you've ever,
I mean it goes up from my, like San Francisco, Steve. Yeah. Yeah.
It goes up forever.
And the first day I think we ran up it and I just thought this is ridiculous
cause you're huffing and puffing or because just like, why would we do this?
Like it just seemed crazy. And then the next day we went there, he went,
we ran like seven miles to signal hill and then Dave Reed and Chris Bruser
decided they want to run up the hill backwards. Really? Which is, you know,
you just run seven miles at probably five 45 pace.
It's six in the morning and they want to run up this huge hill backers and I,
I said no. And I went home. I didn't want to run anymore.
I wanted to be on the debating team and I wanted to read books and I wanted to
hang out with my friend Terry. I quit.
So what is left to say about these genetically based racial differences in your
mind? Very little.
So all the things that we've been talking about in this show that maybe there is
a tendency to get sick in a certain way.
Maybe some medicine's working with a better for one group than another.
Let's say it's still true. Yeah. You say it's true,
but it's not true enough to me when you think about a very short story.
Yeah, it's, I don't, I mean, I'll grant you all those things and then I'll,
I'll roll my eyes and say, I don't really care.
Nelson Gladwell's latest book is called outliers and radio lab will turn it in a
moment.
This is Chad [inaudible] calling you from my living room in Cincinnati, Ohio.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org thanks.
Hey, I'm Jad I boom rod and I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
Our topic today is race. What signs can or cannot tell us about race?
Now that we're at the, towards the back end of the program,
the front end or back end,
we're at the front end of the back and we can confess to what we asked before.
What could a scientist tell us that's hard and true about the biology of race?
Nothing. No. It's better than nothing, right? Something.
But once you dropped the science part of race and think of it as just a way of
sorting into us
as and them's,
then it gets interesting or at the very least more complicated. I didn't know.
Here's an example. We're uptown Manhattan.
1:00 PM third period's about to start where to charter school called facing
history, which has about 150 kids, mostly Hispanic,
and we'd come because we'd heard did every year in the ninth grade they do this
particular guessing exercise. Okay?
All these microphones and other people that you guys see today,
they are not in the room.
You can ignore them like sometimes you want to ignore me. All right?
First Year teacher, David Sharon,
he tells his class with about 12 freshmen to pull up their seats into a
semicircle. Same class style is always,
let's go get on their race goggles. All right,
so we have an activity here called sorting people.
I didn't say, hey, after handing out some worksheets, David kills the lights,
flips on his overhead projector,
and immediately eight faces up here projected onto the wall.
What I want us to do is go kind of one by one and try to decide,
try to come to a consensus. Okay, what race are these people based on?
Looking at them and then we'll test it out.
He explains they've got four choices. That black, white, Asian, native American.
So why don't we start that with the first one? The woman on the top left.
Pink cheeks. Light-Skin bushy hair.
Big Philippina nose. At least that's how it looked to me tomorrow.
What do you think? White Richard Black got her money back.
She just seems white. But then when you look at her hair,
it seems like wishing she's right, baby. I'm gonna go with white.
So what do we think for the man on the bottom left mustache. Borderline Afro.
Asian. Native American. Vaguely ethnic version of Tom Selleck.
I'm picking between white and the Asian.
White or Asian or native American? I think he's black. Black,
Hispanic. We're actually not gonna use Hispanic.
So let's take a vote here. How many people say uh, black? Three.
OK. White or how many people say native American? All right.
Just cut to the chase. After eight of these faces, David revealed the results.
Turned out pink face girl was black,
Tom Selleck was Asian and all in all the class got three right out of eight,
which thrilled. David, what does this tell us?
One of the kids in the back of the class, the girl named Bianca finally says,
well, what it tells us that this activity retarded. Sorry.
It's still why? Cause it's stupid. We have to be more specific.
Okay, so let's say that you had a white mother and a black father.
The child will come out brown. No, come on gray. How would it come out? Great.
No, it will come out brown. Okay. I'm not white or black. I'm Dominican.
Mother is
light-skin like David's color and my father is dark skin and I came out on mixed
color. I am Brown, so is Brown and race. So I guess I'm Brown. Done.
Interestingly in the cafeteria after class,
when we asked people how do they identify,
it's gonna sound like a dumb question,
but what race are you most people said something like this.
Trinidadian Ecuadorian Dominicans. They named the country Mexican. I'm making,
I'm Colombian. Puerto Rican, almost.
No one said I'm one of those four official categories.
If they mentioned it at all,
it was just to say that they're somewhere in between.
Where did they switch back and forth? Half Puerto Rican, half Salvadorian.
I'm a mixture of black people and Spanish. I'm Mexican,
but I'm not a hundred percent Michigan. My spirit is black.
They what I'm saying, if I'm like in my neighborhood,
people will see me a Spanish, but if I go like to my grandma's block,
people will see me as like white. When I go back home to Cuba, everybody, oh,
that's the black end. When I come here,
all of a sudden I changed my race so I become a Spanish. You do that too.
Do I shift like these kids? No. I mean I get, I get confused a lot.
I mean you could pass as a Jew, I think even though you're an Arab. Oh yeah,
in New York, forget it. But what's interesting is these kids,
it wasn't like they were unaware of race. I mean they're aware of it.
It's just fluid for them because I guess so many of them can pass for different
things. It just, it becomes then all about like what you were,
what you listened to, like small things in the end.
But in some circumstances we all know this.
The tiniest differences can suddenly mean everything we talked to.
We're going to switch locations here from New York to Baghdad in Iraq.
We talked to any rocky guy named Ali Abbas who worked as a translator.
As a journalist in Baghdad. Yeah. With NPR, back that office.
And when you were growing up in Baghdad, when you were a kid,
did you know whether you were she or Sunni?
No. No, no.
The first time I knew that I was a senior Shia effect,
it was sixth grade.
We were sitting after class break and someone asked me if I'm a senior,
Shia, like another kid. I remember it was a decree, the kid, the place,
the village we were at. Where should I [inaudible] yeah,
that's the town where sit down grew up. What did you answer? Um, I answered.
I don't know because you really didn't know. I really didn't know.
So they made fun of me, um, and their 10th home and they said to my mom, um,
am I as Tsuneo Shia? The first answer from my mum was a slap on my face.
Weirdly. Yeah. She, she said, never ask about these things.
You're a Muslim and that's all what you care.
[inaudible] but that was then, this is now,
today's is all the in Baghdad. You can't go around saying, I don't know who I am
now.
You'll have to choose. Yeah. Even if you don't want to.
2007, a friend of mine, close friend of mine, he calls me and says, Ellie,
did you hear about what happened to me? And I'm like, no. What happened?
He said, my father, they kidnapped him. His father is an old guy.
62 was just the end in his neighborhood buying candies for his, uh,
grandson. And then he disappeared. Just disappeared. No one knows.
And in Baghdad, when someone's kidnapped, they usually don't come back.
Usually the body just shows up in a more so what alleys friend wanted is he
wanted to go to bag Denmark to go and you know, find his father.
But the problem was his friend couldn't go alone because he suddenly,
his name is Ahmad and the Marc is completely controlled by sheer,
if as Sunni man was trying to get his relatives body out of the morgue,
somewhere along the line, the Shia militia,
they would check the names and they would ask them about something, you know,
shit deep. She had religion questions and if he fails that so they would just,
you know, lunch him, they would, what?
They would take him out of the hospital to somewhere and they probably killed
and dump his body somewhere.
Can I ask a really dumb question? Sure. You walking through Baghdad,
you walk into this hospital and you see a Sunni, you see a Shia.
Can you tell the difference with your eyes at all? Um,
sometimes you can't really know. [inaudible]
sometimes you could take advantage of this confusion to help a friend,
Ali, after all was always helping journalists get around Baghdad.
And you never knew who was going to be asking you questions.
Sometimes it would be a Sunni malicious, sometimes a Shia militia.
It's very hard to know.
So journalists would go around the town with two ideas simultaneously.
One would be a sheer id, the other a SUNY item
and they're putting it like somewhere in their pockets.
You know the right is the Sydney, the left is this year. Wait a second.
The riders, the Sunni, the the left is this year. Yeah.
So if in that split second you think this Guy Sunni,
you go right and the few share your go left. That's new. If it were me, I just,
I know that, I know how I thought. I know what happened just to shoot a gun.
Right. But it's not traded. It's not really fun though.
Especially when your job on this particular day is to take your Sunni friend
into a hospital controlled by Shia militia.
So our lead decided that to protect his Sunni friend Amar,
maybe the best protection would be a slight name change.
When they went to the hospital, they would call him Amar,
not Amare Amato.
Is that a pure suddenly name? Amar is something in the middle.
Could be senior condition as the same as the different spellings,
different spelling. Yeah, different spellings. They said almost identical,
but just the LF or the a in the middle.
And by adding that one letter,
that one extra a really hoped that would keep his friend alive.
So we went there, I took him and my brother was here who's also a physician. Um,
at that time came with us.
He came with us and I told him not to call Omar Omar.
I told him to call [inaudible].
So Ali and his friend and his brother using this new name that into the morgue
where they were taken to a room where everybody sits to look at pictures of
people who, who are dead. We sat them that computer room, they call it,
where they're like seven computer monitors and there's someone on the side of
the room while he's holding the, uh, the mouse and he's moving with his finger.
The, the pictures changing the pictures and pupils sitting on the ground.
Probably 35 or 40 other people on the ground looking at the pictures,
hoping not to see
a picture of their brother or their mother or their father.
So whenever there's a picture of one of their relatives,
you will hear someone crying, shouting, wailing.
We were looking at the pictures, looking at the pictures
too. After picture after picture,
you know, we finally found,
reached a decision that his father wasn't among the pictures.
Suddenly his father's picture comes out,
[inaudible]
Delmar, burst out crying and you know, and my brother would say,
Omar, don't worry, I'm won't, don't Amar. This is guts decision.
This is guts that Dah Dah, Dah. And then you'd say that you take now Amar, Amar,
and Marla and our, you know, hit him on his chest. Don't say this word,
don't say it, because not only Omar will be killed, it will be us.
Well,
but nobody in the room apparently heard him say Amare the wrong pronunciation.
So they got a number from the picture and then they had to go to a different
part of the morgue to actually locate the body.
Then of course bring it home for proper burial.
So we, we walked out from the computer room, we went to the, uh,
to their frigerator, which is actually not that refrigerator,
it's just hallways.
All these buddies dumped on both sides of the hallway and as soon as you enter
these hallways, you can barely hold your breath. The smell,
the auto is so, so stringent.
It's like it's impossible to bear and the whole ground is full of a thick layer
of, of greasy blood, you know, it sticks to your foot when you work.
It's like chicks chicks
and it was a very long hallway.
Omar was, um,
he actually fell twice and we would stop him from falling down and we would slap
him on his face, wake up. We've got to keep going.
So we would walk all the way down to find all these piles of buddy.
Then in one pile, the guy who's wearing boots,
the worker there who will tell us,
I think our father is within this pile and he's like talking normally
[inaudible] and bothered by all of this.
Who through the buddies from this side or from this side.
And then he took a Omar's father from his arms and he just pulled him from
underneath the pile.
And I'm didn't want to believe that this was his father.
He didn't want to believe. He said, I don't know. I,
I don't think this is my father. I don't see him,
but the tag number was there and because the tag number was there,
they knew it was Kumar's father. We came out and we thought, you know, that's,
that's it. We're going to take the buddy and go home.
And at that moment
they were suddenly approached by two Shia militiamen over.
Very obvious. They're shits from the media,
from one of the most radical groups in Baghdad. And um,
one of them said, let me see your id though.
I'm going to have to give him his physician's ID.
But that ID had his real name, his SUNY name on it. He looked at it,
so I'm not, he said, Huh? He said, Oh, Ma.
Huh.
So he knew. Anyway, you're saying is yeah,
he talked to his friend next to him.
They kept whispering to each other about the nit and we realized probably that's
the moment when we're all going to die. Yeah, we're done.
[inaudible]
so immediately, immediately we started talking to them in a very loud voice.
Listen guys, we are your colleagues here. Whatever you need,
come to the emergency room. Ask for me. I'm Dr Ali Abbas and this is,
my brother has such a bus, you know, to show them that we're shit.
We started talking in a very, uh, heavy sheer accent, you know. Um, yeah,
you can come at any moment if you wanted the, uh, if you have anything,
just tell us. Let us know. We're your brothers. Help us here.
And then they waited.
[inaudible] kept looking at their eyes when they're doing it and
[inaudible]
God, they gave us the papers back.
We've got the ominous father out and he took him and buried him.
[inaudible]
Ali Abbas has now left back that he's moved to Brooklyn, New York neighborhood.
Very proud of its mix of races and people from all over the world.
But remember, Baghdad was a multicultural city as well,
for hundreds of years longer than Brooklyn. So I asked him,
now that you're here, I mean, given what you've, what you've seen,
what do you think about us that would tell you something? The subway is my,
I would sit in a subway car, you know, and, and, and looking at the people,
African Americans, Hispanic, white, you know, I question myself, he's a Jew.
He's not a Jew, he's Christian.
And I'm looking at the people and it's exactly this question that comes in my
mind, who, how they're living together.
How does it seem like something that could explode? Oh yeah.
It's something that I always think, I mean,
I look at them and look at all kinds of phrases and I'm wondering how can this
country hold them together?
[inaudible]
that was Ali Abbas, often a translator for national public radio. Okay.
Time to go. radiolab.org is our website, radio lab at w n y C. Dot.
Org is our email. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.